my beautiful friends I would like to
introduce you to Christian Grey Oh No we
started this book club to stimulate our
minds from what I hear this book is
quite stimulating that's not mine I've
never seen that book before
honestly this is nasty have you ever
been spanked
huh this book has got me in a total
tizzy come in the zip ties are you
thinking about tying me up what nothing
is just
diplom our age were meant to have sex
God wouldn't do what he does to our
bodies
speak for yourself well that was not God
that was dr. Nazira yo you just need to
put yourself out there to judge - yes
your love life with these tips do you
need anything else you're on the man of
your dreams is just a click away no I
don't I'm fine thank you
yep slam oh come on what's it been 40
years since when do you eat ice cream I
got a brain freeze here give that to a
professional God it's the first day so
put on something sexy just be
comfortable that's too comfortable right
well hey I love a man difference
[Music]
everybody remembers their first kiss how
about I tell you about my best kiss
maybe that hasn't happened yet
I never thought I'd be back here again
is it as good as you remember maybe
better
[Music]
mom you need to be a little bit
realistic there's a man out there who
makes me feel things that I didn't think
we're so positive this than you think
maybe things with us will go bust but
that's life and I'm not through living
Minds just yet
[Music]
I can't believe you put viagra in my
beer need you to step out of the vehicle
I don't think that's a good idea of sir
[Music]
okay enjoy your night
you too thank you
[Music]
you